recientemente o definitivamente a lo
largo de los últimos años se ha hablado
mucho acerca de la idea del diseño
inteligente y cómo se compara con la
evolución y mi objetivo en este vídeo no
es entrar en ese debate que en realidad
ya se ha convertido en una discusión en
varios círculos sino hacer mi mejor
esfuerzo para reconciliar estas dos
ideas y la idea detrás del diseño
inteligente es que hay algunas cosas que
vemos en nuestro mundo que son tan
increíbles que es difícil creer que
podrían ser el producto de una serie de
procesos aleatorios y el ejemplo que
normalmente se da para esto es el ojo
humano que es un instrumento realmente
asombroso hace unas cosas increíbles
puede enfocarse a diferentes instancias
enfoca la luz en un punto específico y
también está el nervio óptico y tenemos
dos ojos para poder tener visión
estereoscópica o visión tridimensional
podemos ver a colores y los ojos se
pueden ajustar a la luz y a la
obscuridad
así que el ojo humano es verdaderamente
asombroso y el argumento que utilizan es
como pudo haber sido creado por medio de
procesos aleatorios y mi objetivo no es
rastrear la evolución del ojo pero haré
una pequeña nota al margen aquí la
evolución y la selección natural y me
gusta más utilizar el término selección
natural porque no habla de un proceso
activo la selección natural ha estado
actuando durante millones y millones de
años y vemos pruebas en nuestro mundo de
una progresión de diferentes tipos de
ojos de hecho todas las pruebas
demuestran que el ojo humano no es
perfecto y que hay variación en el ojo
humano es decir todos sabemos que
algunos tenemos miopía o hipermetropía o
astigmatismo que el ojo se degenera con
el tiempo y algunas personas generan
cataratas entonces hay una serie de
problemas que el ojo puede tener no
estoy usando esto para refutar el
argumento del diseño inteligente solo
estoy mostrando que si hay una variación
incluso en lo que creo que es
verdaderamente una pieza increíble de
biología e incluso si nos vamos fuera
del mundo humano hay un enorme espectro
de ojos hay peces en el fondo del mar
que tienen ojos que en realidad solo son
sensores de luz que apenas si pueden
percibir si hay luz o calor alrededor y
algunos insectos también son así y luego
por otro lado hay algunos ojos que son
mucho mejores que los ojos humanos hay
algunas aves y algunos tipos de
criaturas nocturnas que pueden ver en la
obscuridad los gatos por ejemplo tienen
un material reflectante en los ojos que
les permite ver mejor en la noche y
pueden ver igual de bien que los humanos
durante el día así que podríamos decir
que sus ojos son superiores a los de los
seres humanos hay algunas aves que
pueden ver con mucha mayor claridad a
distancias mucho mayores de lo que los
humanos podemos alcanzar a ver por lo
que no hay ningún ojo perfecto
ahora hablaré un poco desde un punto de
vista teológico y para aquellos de
ustedes que ven los vídeos de khan
academy saben que normalmente no tocamos
los argumentos teológicos aunque en
algún momento se podría hacer toda una
lista de reproducción sobre filosofía
pero quiero ser muy cuidadosa de no
ofender a nadie aquí ya que esa
verdaderamente no es mi intención pero
el punto que quiero hacer es que si tú
crees en un dios y no pretendo tomar
lados en este argumento en este vídeo es
hasta cierto punto casi despectivo de un
ser todopoderoso decir que este ojo
humano es perfecto eso nos da demasiada
importancia a nosotros como individuos
siempre pienso que debemos ser humildes
en nuestras vidas y debemos darnos
cuenta de que nosotros como seres
humanos no somos perfectos que este ojo
no es perfecto y querer dar a entender
que esto es lo mejor que una entidad
perfecta o una entidad todopoderosa
podría producir creo que es un poco
despectivo
te voy a dar otro ejemplo y ahora
entraré en mi papel de ingeniero y una
vez más quiero ser muy clara mi objetivo
en este vídeo no es decir que la
evolución y los procesos aleatorios lo
son todo y que todo se da por sí solo y
que no existe dios y que solo tienes que
vivir con la evolución no ese no es mi
punto de hecho estoy argumentando lo
opuesto a eso que la creencia en un dios
universal y todopoderoso no concuerda
con un dios que diseña cada cosa de
manera particular incluso las
imperfecciones que vemos alrededor y
sobre todo porque en ellas vemos
variación y así se da a la selección
natural es decir nosotros no podemos
sólo enfocarnos en el ojo deberíamos
también enfocarnos en los virus y el
cáncer y tendríamos que hablar de un
dios que está diseñando una por una cada
versión de cada secuencia de adn que
vemos porque si alguien habla de diseñar
un ojo
sabemos que el ojo es el subproducto del
adn
y sabemos que el adn es una secuencia de
pares de bases por ejemplo ate que se a
y hay miles de millones de ellos así que
cuando hablamos de diseño estaríamos
hablando literalmente del diseño de la
secuencia de adn y sabemos que en la
secuencia hay algo de ruido y sabemos
que gran parte de ella proviene de virus
primitivos que existieron hace muchísimo
tiempo así que lo que estoy argumentando
aquí es que con el fin de dar crédito a
dios todopoderoso por lo menos en mi
opinión un sistema que viene de ideas
básicas muy simples y elegantes como la
selección natural y las variaciones que
nuestro adn las llamamos mutaciones de
pie a que emerjan sistemas más complejos
y esto es lo que la evolución nos dice
que nuestro universo es este entorno tan
vasto donde a partir de estas ideas tan
básicas sencillas y hermosas tenemos
esta estructura tan compleja que es
verdaderamente asombrosa me parece que
esto es de lo que habla la evolución
en mi opinión incluso desde el punto de
vista de la ingeniería esto habla de una
forma superior de diseño esto nos habla
de un diseño más profundo y el hecho de
que sea un diseño más profundo no
necesariamente implica que tiene un
diseñador tú tienes la libertad de
llegar a esa conclusión o no con base en
tus creencias así que el punto de este
vídeo es que si tú crees en un dios y
como ya dije no voy a tomar partido por
ninguno de los lados en este vídeo un
dios que habla de belleza y elegancia y
es infinitamente poderoso entonces esta
idea de las leyes de la física la
química y la selección natural que en
realidad cuando hable sobre la selección
natural en el último vídeo creo que
puedes coincidir conmigo en que tiene
bastante sentido común que este es un
diseño muy profundo y habla del arte del
diseñador en lugar de diseñar cada una
de estas entidades una por una y lo que
es aún más profundo acerca del diseño es
que es adaptable
si hay estrés ambiental entonces las
otras variaciones sobreviven más
frecuentemente así que está en constante
cambio esa perfección en la que no hay
un instante que pueda ser señalado y
decir este es el punto más alto al que
puede llegar este diseño que siempre
está no quiero decir en mejora constante
pero siempre está más adaptado a su
entorno conforme éste cambia y esto es
para mí un mejor diseño
ahora bien dándole seguimiento a eso y
quiero ser muy clara esta idea es sólo
para elevar el estándar de lo que
esperamos del diseño es para mostrar
otros puntos u otros lugares en el mundo
científico matemático donde esto también
surge y el mejor ejemplo que veo de
ellos son los fractales algunos de
ustedes podrán haber visto antes el
conjunto de mandelbrot un conjunto de
fractales muy famoso y es inmensamente
complejo
de hecho podrías ampliar la imagen una y
otra vez en cualquier punto del conjunto
de mandelbrot y cuando lees la imagen se
vuelve infinitamente complejo y podrías
explorar
carlo indefinidamente pero la verdadera
belleza de este conjunto es que todo
esto puede ser descrito por una ecuación
una ecuación sorprendentemente sencilla
y es esta ecuación la siguiente zeta es
igual a la zeta anterior al cuadrado más
c y podrían decir pero si empezaste
hablando de diseño inteligente y
evolución porque ahora estás hablando de
fractales y el punto que estoy tratando
de hacer aquí es que si tuviera dos
diseñadores y uno de ellos decidiera
pintar este fractal y decir voy a
dibujar esto en color café y voy a hacer
esta parte en azul y voy a hacer aquí un
círculo con otros círculos diríamos que
este es un pintor increíble por ejemplo
si hace 300 años le mostrarás este
conjunto a alguien diría que se trata
del mejor diseño que alguien haya podido
concebir debido a que es tan
infinitamente complejo
pero ahora sabemos que esto puede ser
completamente descrito por esta simple
ecuación para aquellos de ustedes que
están interesados aquí tenemos un plano
complejo y empezamos en cero así que por
cada punto en el plano complejo le
asignamos ese valor a c y empezamos con
cero y seguimos haciendo esto de manera
que decimos cero al cuadrado más ese
número complejo es igual a esto a
continuación ponemos ese valor aquí y
luego elevamos ese número al cuadrado
más ese número complejo y lo hacemos una
y otra y otra vez así resulta que
algunos números no tienden a infinito y
esos números están en negro no están
considerados como parte del conjunto de
mandelbrot y los números que sí tienden
a infinito conforme y tiramos en esta
fórmula los colores según qué tan rápido
divergen a infinito y esto crea este
patrón infinitamente complejo y hermoso
si dijéramos cuál es el diseño más
profundo el diseño más significativo y
pudieras preguntarle esto a un ingeniero
te diría que este es el diseño más
profundo porque es simple y elegante
pero describe algo de complejidad
infinita no sólo se centra en lo
particular se centra en un nivel más
allá se centra en crear la idea de la
cual este fractal es sólo un ejemplo
este probablemente es el vídeo en el que
mas divagó y donde me alejo más de la
ciencia y quizás me centro un poco más
en la metafísica y en lo asombroso de
todo esto pero mi objetivo aquí es dar a
conocer un poco la idea de cómo se
pueden conciliar estas nociones que la
evolución la aleatoriedad de su
naturaleza no necesariamente habla de un
universo sin dios aunque no voy a tomar
partido en esto sino que habla de un
dios más profundo al menos para mí así
que bueno discúlpame por tomarme estas
libertades y quiero dejar muy claro que
no no quiero ofender a nadie solo quería
darles a conocer
esta idea nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo